The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN V. OPPENHEIM:
In the last lecture,
we introduced the class
of discrete time systems,
and in particular, imposed the
conditions of linearity first
of all, and second, the
property or constraint of shift
invariance.
And those constraints led
us to the convolution sum
representation.
In today's lecture,
there are several issues
that I'd like to focus on.
The first is the introduction
of two additional constraints
that it's sometimes useful to
impose, or at least consider,
for discrete time systems--
namely the constraints
or conditions
of causality and stability.
Second of all, I would like to
talk about a particular class,
or at least introduce
a particular class
of linear shift
invariant systems, namely
those representable by linear
constant coefficient difference
equations.
And finally, I'd
like to introduce
a representation of linear
shift invariant systems
that is an alternative to the
convolution sum representation,
and in particular,
that representation
corresponds to the
representation in terms
of a frequency response.
Well, let's begin
with the notions
of stability and causality,
reminding you, first of all,
that, as we talked
about last time,
we can consider a
general system--
inputs and outputs
are sequences--
and in general, the system
just simply corresponds
to some transformation
from the input sequence
to the output sequence.
When we impose the conditions of
linearity and shift invariance,
both conditions, then we can
express the output sequence
in this form where h
of n is the response
of the system to a unit sample.
And this can also be
rearranged in the form
that I've indicated here,
essentially interchanging
the role of the unit sample
response and the input.
The sum expressed in
either of these two forms,
we referred to last time
as the convolution sum.
So the convolution
sum comes out of--
or is a consequence of--
linearity and shift invariance.
Two additional conditions
are stability and causality.
Stability of a
system, in general,
corresponds to the statement
that if the input sequence
is bounded--
in other words, if x of
n, essentially if x of n
is finite for all n, including
as n goes to infinity,
then a system is
said to be stable
if the output sequence,
y of n, is also bounded.
In other words, the magnitude
of y of n is finite for all n.
If that's true for any
bounded input sequence
that the output
sequence is bounded,
the system is said to be stable.
Now, that's a
statement that applies
to general discrete
time systems.
For the specific class of
systems that we'll be dealing
with in this set of lessons,
namely the class of linear
shift invariant systems, you
can show that an equivalent
statement of stability-- or
a necessary and sufficient
condition for this to be true--
is simply that the unit
sample response of the system
be absolutely summable.
In other words, that the
sum of the magnitudes
of the values in the unit
sample response are finite.
For example, if we had a
unit sample response which
was 2 to the n times a unit
step, 2 to the n, of course,
as n increases--
as n goes from 0 to infinity--
2 the n grows
exponentially, in fact.
And so, obviously, this is
not absolutely summable.
So this is an example of a
system that would be unstable.
Whereas, if h of n were a
1/2 to the n times u of n,
so that for n greater than 0--
and less than 0, of course,
both of these are 0--
for n greater than 0, this
were decaying exponentially,
if you sum up these
values from 0 to infinity,
it converges to a finite number.
So that this, in fact, would
correspond to a stable system.
Now, we have the
option, of course,
of talking about unstable
systems or stable systems.
Generally, it is
true that stability
is a condition on a system
that it's useful to impose.
In other words, generally,
we would like our systems
to be stable, although
there are actually
some cases where
unstable systems are
useful to talk about.
The second property or condition
that it is useful sometimes
to consider, is the
condition of causality.
And causality, first of
all, for a general system,
is a statement basically
that the system doesn't
respond before you kick it.
In other words, if we have
an input, x of n, the output,
y of n, for some value
of n-- let's say n 1--
depends only on x of n
for previous values of n.
So for any n 1, the
statement is that y of n
only depends on x of n for
previous values of x of n.
In other words, the system
can't anticipate the values
that are going to be coming in.
For a linear shift
invariant system,
we can show that a necessary
and sufficient condition
for causality is that the unit
sample response of the system
be 0 for n less than 0.
In other words, if the unit
sample response of the system
is 0 for n less
than 0, the system
is guaranteed to be causal.
If it's not 0 for n less
than 0, then the system
is guaranteed not to be causal.
Just for example, if we had a
unit sample response which was
2 to the n times u of minus n--
in other words, 0 for n
greater than 0, and 2 the n
for n less than 0,
this, of course,
would correspond to
a non-causal system,
since the unit sample
response has non-zero values
for negative values of n.
And we could also
examine stability.
It would turn out that this
corresponds to a stable system,
although in the previous
example, we had talked about 2
to the n for n
positive corresponds
to an unstable system.
The point is that if
you look at 2 to the n
as the index n runs
negative, then that is--
as n runs negative,
it's an exponential
that's decaying in
negative values of n.
So then, in fact, this
is absolutely summable--
that makes it stable, but
it's obviously non-causal.
Now, I want to stress--
it's a very important
point to stress--
that causality is, of
course, a useful thing
to inquire about about a
system, it's useful to ask,
is the system causal
or is it not causal?
But generally, it is
not necessarily true
that causality is a
condition that we'll
want to impose on the system.
There are many examples of
useful, non-causal systems,
and in many
instances, we'll want
to talk about systems
which are non-causal.
So again, it's useful
to inquire about
whether a system is
causal or not causal,
but it is not generally useful
to constrain ourselves to talk
only about causal systems.
The story is somewhat different
for stability in the sense
that an unstable system
is somewhat less useful
than a non-causal system.
So these are two additional
conditions, or properties,
that we'll sometimes want
to inquire about when
we talk about a system.
In general, for linear
shift invariant systems,
there is a wide latitude
in terms of the description
of those systems.
And that is a similar
type of statement
that applies in the
continuous time case, also.
Just as in the
continuous time case,
it is useful to
concentrate, in many cases,
on systems that can
be implemented with
r's, l's, and c's--
and consequently
are representable
by linear constant coefficient
differential equations.
In the discrete time
case, it's often
useful to concentrate
on systems that
are describable by linear
constant coefficient difference
equations.
So I would like to
just briefly introduce
the class of systems
which are representable
by linear constant coefficient
difference equations.
And the discussion
in this lecture
is only a brief introduction,
and we'll, in fact,
be returning to this
class of systems
several times over
this set of lessons.
We refer to an Nth order--
linear constant coefficient
difference equation--
as being in the form
that I've indicated here.
And what it consists of
is a linear combination
of the delayed output sequences
equal to a linear combination
of delayed input sequences.
A differential equation, of
course, in continuous time
involves linear
combinations of derivatives.
The corresponding situation
in the discrete time case,
is a linear combination
of differences.
So this is, then, a
general Nth order, linear--
in the sense that it's
a linear combination--
constant coefficient-- meaning
that these are constant
numbers, as opposed to
being functions of n--
difference equation--
meaning it involves
differences of the input
and output sequence.
The order of the
difference equation
generally is used to refer to
the number of delays required
in the output sequence.
In general, the number of
delays in the input sequence, M,
does not have to be equal to N.
But it's generally convenient
to refer to the order
as corresponding
to the number of delays
involved in the output sequence.
For the 0th order
difference equation,
the solution if it corresponds
to a representation
of a linear shift
and invariant system,
the solution is trivial--
very straightforward.
Particular, let's examine
what this difference equation
reduces to, if N is equal to 0.
And just for
convenience, we'll choose
the coefficients
to be normalized
so that a sub 0 is equal to 1.
Obviously anything I
say is straightforwardly
generalized for a
0 not equal to 1,
but that's just a convenient
normalization to impose.
All right, if N is equal to
0, and a 0 is equal to 1,
then what this
equation looks like
is just on the left hand side,
y of n, and the right hand side
as it is.
So we have y of n is
equal to this sum.
And that looks suspiciously
like the convolution sum--
it involves a linear combination
only of delayed input
sequences.
And so, in fact, this is
identical to the convolution
sum.
If we thought of this, say,
as h of r, h of r, then,
is equal to b sub r.
So the unit sample response
corresponding to the 0th order
difference equation is just
this set of coefficients,
and, of course, r
runs only from 0 to M,
so it's the coefficients b
sub n for n between 0 and M.
And it's equal to 0, otherwise.
So that's very straightforward.
We can pick off the
solution, essentially,
by recognizing this as
the convolution sum.
Obviously, another way of
obtaining the unit sample
response corresponding
to this system
is simply to plug in a
unit sample for x of n.
And you'll see, in fact,
that what comes rolling out
are these coefficients
b sub r, or b sub n.
So if this is used to describe
a linear shift invariant system,
the unit sample response
corresponds simply
to the coefficients in
the difference equation.
For n not equal to 0, it's
not quite as straightforward
as that.
First of all, let me point
out that for N not equal to 0,
the left hand side of this
equation involves y of n,
y of n minus 1, y of
minus 2, et cetera,
up to y of little
n minus capital N.
We can take all of the terms
except the one involving y of n
over to the right hand
side of the equation,
and end up with
an equation which
expresses y of n as a linear
combination of delayed inputs,
and a linear combination
of past output sequences.
If we rewrite this
equation in this form--
and again, just for
convenience, we'll
choose a 0 equal to 1, simply
normalizing that coefficient.
Then, the difference
equation that we end up
with is in the form that
I've indicated here, y of n
is a linear combination of
delayed input sequences minus--
because we brought that from
the other side of the equation--
minus a linear
combination of past--
of the previous output values.
What that says is
that we presumably
can iterate this equation,
or equivalently, what it says
is that the difference
equation corresponds
to an explicit input/output
relationship for the system,
because if somehow we could
get the equation going,
then we can solve for y of
n-- we can solve for y of n
if we have the right
previous values for y of n.
And then we can solve
for y of n plus 1, y of n
plus 2, et cetera.
In other words, we can continue
to iterate the equation.
What's required to
do that are that we
have to know the input--
and we assume, of course,
that we know that--
and we have to know some
previous output values.
And to know the
previous output values,
then, means that there is some
additional information that we
have to specify, and
those we'll generally
refer to as the
boundary conditions,
or the initial conditions.
For example, let's
see how this equation
would work if we focused
on the first order case.
So the first order case,
capital N is equal to 1.
We have the equation, y of
n minus a, y of n minus 1
equals x of n.
And let's find the unit sample
response for the system--
in other words, choosing x
of n equal to a unit sample.
And for the initial
conditions, let's assume
that, for a unit sample
input, the output is
equal to 0 for n less than 0.
Now, when we do that, we're
making a specific assumption
about causality--
we're imposing the
boundary conditions
that the unit sample response
has to be 0 for n less than 0--
that's exactly the necessary
and sufficient condition
that we need for causality.
So basically, we're saying that
we're imposing on the solution
that we're about to generate,
the additional condition
of causality.
All right, well now,
rewriting this equation
by taking this term over
to the right hand side,
and taking account of
the fact that we're
considering the input
to be a unit sample,
we have the output
sequences unit
sample plus a times the
output sequence delayed.
And now let's run through an
iteration of this equation,
obtaining some
successive values.
y of minus 1 we can
get simply by referring
to the initial condition.
We stated there y of n
is 0 for n less than 0,
and so that means, of course,
that y of minus 1 is 0.
y of 0 is equal to delta of
0, but that's equal to 1,
plus a times y of
minus 1, which was 0.
So y of 0 is equal to 1.
y of 1 is equal to
delta of 1, which is 0--
the unit sample is only
non-0 at n equals 0.
So that 0 plus a times y of 0--
y of 0 is equal to 1--
so y of 1 is equal
to a times 1, or a.
y of 2, if we follow that
through, is equal to a squared.
And if you run through
a few more of those,
you'll see rather quickly that
what we get for the unit sample
response, imposing the
condition of causality,
is that the unit sample
response is a to the N for n
greater than 0.
Of course, it's 0 for
n less than 0, because
of our initial condition.
So it's a to N times u of n.
And it's obviously causal,
because that's what we imposed.
It may or may not be stable,
depending on the value of a.
In particular, if the
magnitude of a is less than 1,
then this sequence will
be decaying exponentially
as n increases.
So for the magnitude
of a less than 1,
this corresponds
to a stable system.
Now this isn't the
only initial condition
that we can impose on
the system and still
have it correspond to a
linear shift invariant system.
We could, alternatively,
impose a different set
of initial conditions,
which is the--
or boundary conditions,
really, because they're not,
for this case,
initial conditions--
boundary conditions
that state instead
of the statement that
the system is causal,
the statement that the
system is totally non-causal.
What I mean is, let's
take the same example--
the same difference equation--
let's again choose the
input to be a unit sample,
but let's impose another
condition on the solution,
boundary condition.
Namely that the
unit sample response
is 0 for n greater
than 0, rather than
the boundary condition that says
that it's 0 for n less than 0.
In that case, it's convenient
to generate the solution
iteratively by running the
difference equation backwards,
in other words, by
expressing y of n minus 1,
in terms of y of n and x
of n-- this is just simply
another rearrangement of
the difference equation.
And with this initial condition,
if we look at y of 1--
of course, y of 1 is equal to
0 by virtue of the boundary
condition that we've imposed,
so this is equal to 0--
y of 0 corresponds to n
equal to 1 in this equation.
So n equal to 1 here, we have
1 over a times y of 1, which is
0 minus delta of 1 which is 0.
So y of 0 is again equal to 0.
y of minus 1 corresponds
to n equal to 0,
so we have 1 over a times
y of 0, which was 0,
minus delta of 0, which is 1.
So we get minus a
minus to the minus 1.
y of minus 2, we would
substitute n equals minus 1.
y of minus 1 we had as
minus a to the minus 1.
And delta of minus 1 is
0, so we have here minus a
to the minus 2, and it
continues on that way.
And if you generated
some more of these,
what you'd see rather
quickly is that this
is of the form minus a to the
n times u of minus n minus 1.
In other words, it is an
exponential to form a to the n,
as we found for the
causal solution, also.
But it's 0 for n greater
than 0, and it's of the form
a to the n for n less than 0.
What that means,
in particular, is
that if we again
inquired as to whether it
was stable or unstable, for
the magnitude of a less than 1,
what we would
find, in this case,
is that it's unstable
rather than stable.
So what we've
seen, then, is that
a linear constant coefficient
difference equation, by itself,
doesn't specify
uniquely a system--
it requires a set of
initial conditions.
And depending on the initial
conditions or boundary
conditions that are
imposed, it may correspond
to a causal system,
or it may correspond
to a non-causal system.
And in some situations,
we might want
it to correspond to
either one of those two.
Something that I haven't
stated explicitly,
but there is some discussion
of this in the text,
is the fact that it is not
for every set of boundary
conditions that a linear
constant coefficient difference
equation corresponds to a
linear shift invariant system,
but it does in particular
for the two sets of boundary
conditions that
are imposed here.
More generally, what's required
of the boundary conditions,
so that the difference equation
corresponds to a linear shift
invariant system, is that
the boundary conditions
have to be consistent
with the statement
that if the input, x of
n were 0, 0 for all n,
that the output would
also be 0 for all n.
And there is some additional
discussion of this in the text.
I indicate also that we'll be
returning from time to time
to further discussion of linear
constant coefficient difference
equations, and discussing,
in particular, other ways
of solving this
class of equations.
For the remainder
of the lecture,
I'd like to focus on an
alternative representation
of linear shift
invariant systems,
alternative to the time
domain, or convolution sum
representation, that we dealt
with in the last lecture.
In particular, the
very useful alternative
is a description of linear
shift invariant systems in terms
of its frequency response.
In other words, in
terms of its response
either to sinusoidal
excitations,
or to complex
exponential excitations.
Well, the basic notion
behind the frequency response
description of linear
shift invariant systems
is the fact that
complex exponentials
are eigenfunctions of linear
shift invariant systems.
What I mean by that is that for
linear shift invariant systems,
if you put in a
complex exponential,
you get out a
complex exponential.
And the only change is
in the complex amplitude
of the complex exponential--
the functional form is
the same, so complex
exponential in gives you
a complex exponential out.
We can see that rather
easily by referring
to the convolution sum
description of linear shift
invariant systems, as
I've indicated here.
In particular, suppose that we
choose an input sequence which
is a complex exponential.
And let's substitute this
into this expression,
so that the output is
then the sum of h of k
e to the j omega n minus k.
This term can be decomposed into
a product of two exponentials,
e to the j omega n, and
e to the minus j omega k.
And since e to the j omega n
doesn't depend on the index k,
we can take that
piece outside the sum,
and what we're
left with is y of n
is e to the j omega n
times the sum of h of k
e to the minus j omega k,
as I've indicated up here.
So we started with a
complex exponential sequence
going into the system.
None of this stuff
over here depends on n,
so when we sum all that
up, that's just a number--
it's a function
of omega, depends
on what complex
frequency we've put in.
But it doesn't depend on n.
And, in fact,
notationally, we'll
refer to this as the
H of e to the j omega.
So consequently,
the output sequence,
due to a complex
exponential input,
is this number, or
function of omega, times
e of the j omega n.
The change in the
complex amplitude, then,
is H of e to the j omega,
but the functional form
of the output is the same as the
functional form of the input.
And that's what we
mean when we say
that the complex exponential
is an eigenfunction
of a linear shift
invariant system.
So finally, H of e to the j
omega is given by this sum--
I've just changed the
index of summation
from what I had up here,
but obviously that's
no important change.
And we will refer to this,
or to H of e to the j omega,
as the frequency
response of the system.
One of the reasons why
the frequency response
is important--
of course, one of the facts
that you can see right away
is that it's easily
obtained directly
from the unit sample response.
One of the reasons why the
frequency response is useful
is because it's essentially
the frequency response that
allows us to obtain quite easily
the response of the system
to sinusoidal excitations.
And, as we'll see
in later lectures,
starting actually
with the next lecture,
essentially arbitrary sequences
can be represented either
as linear combinations
of complex exponentials,
or as linear combinations
of sinusoidal sequences.
And so, if we know
what the response is
to a complex exponential
or to sinusoidal sequences,
we can, in effect,
describe the response
to arbitrary sequences.
We'll see all of that coming
up in the next lecture.
But to see how this
frequency response relates
to the sinusoidal response,
the relation essentially
pops out from the
fact that if we
have a sinusoidal excitation,
a sinusoidal excitation
can be represented as a
linear combination of two
complex exponentials--
as I've indicated here.
So a over 2 to the j
phi, e to j omega 0 n,
this is one complex exponential
with a complex frequency omega
0, and a complex amplitude,
a over 2 e to j phi.
Then its complex
conjugate term, those two
added up give us a
complex exponential.
We can find the response
to each of these simply
from the frequency response.
We know that all that happens
to a complex exponential
is that its complex
amplitude gets multiplied
by the frequency response.
And so this is one complex
exponential, and another one.
We're talking about
linear systems,
so the response of
the sum of these two
is the sum of the responses.
And so if we express the
frequency response in a polar
form, as I've indicated here,
in terms of magnitude and phase,
and if you track through what
happens when you multiply each
of these complex exponentials
by the appropriate frequency
response-- this one at
a frequency omega 0,
this one at a frequency
minus omega 0--
and add the terms
back together again,
the resulting
output sequence has
a change in real amplitude
given by, or dictated
by the magnitude of
the frequency response,
and a change in phase dictated
by the angle of the frequency
response.
In other words, by
this theta of omega.
So the frequency response,
when thought of in polar form--
magnitude and angle--
the magnitude represents the
change in the real amplitude
of a sinusoidal excitation.
And the angle, or
complex argument,
represents the phase shift.
And that is exactly
analogous, exactly
identical to what we're used
to in the continuous time case.
Well, let's just
look at an example
of a simple linear
shift invariant system,
and the resulting
frequency response.
Let's return to the first
order difference equation
that we talked about
just a short time ago.
We saw that there
were two solutions
that we could generate
for this, depending
on whether we
assumed that it was
a causal or non-causal system.
Let's focus on the causal case.
If the system was causal,
we generated, essentially,
iteratively the solution that
the unit sample response is
a to the n times u of n.
And let's assume that we're
talking about a stable system,
so that a is magnitude
of a is less than 1--
of course, this could be
negative and still be stable
between minus 1 and 0.
I'll assume in the pictures
that I draw that a is, in fact,
positive, and then
also less than 1.
Now, the expression for
the frequency response
of the system, from what
we derived just above,
is the sum overall n of h of n
times e to the minus j omega n.
Because of the unit step in
here, the limits on the sum
change from 0 to infinity--
in other words, all of this
is going to be 0 from minus
infinity up to 0, because
of the unit step.
For n greater than
0, we have a to the n
times this exponential, so
we have a to the n times
e to the--
surely there's a
minus sign there--
e to the minus j omega n.
If we sum this, this is just
the sum of a geometric series.
In other words,
it's of the form,
the sum of alpha to the n--
alpha equals 0 to infinity.
Sums of this form are equal
to 1 over 1 minus alpha.
And alpha, in this case, is
a e to the minus j omega.
So that sum, then, is 1 over 1
minus a e to the minus j omega.
Well, as we saw--
at least for the
sinusoidal response--
it's useful to look at the
magnitude and phase of this,
in other words, to look
at it in polar form.
So if we want the magnitude
of this frequency response,
we can obtain that
by multiplying this
by its complex conjugate.
Consequently, the magnitude
of the frequency response
is given by H of
e to the j omega--
the minus sign is
conveniently there for us--
multiplied by its
complex conjugate, which
is 1 minus a e to the minus--
I'm sorry, 1 over 1 minus
a 3 to the plus j omega.
If we multiply these together,
then what we obtain is 1 over 1
plus a squared minus 2
a times cosine omega.
And the phase angle of this is
equal to the arctangent of--
if you just simply
work this out--
the arctangent of a
sine omega divided
by 1 minus a cosine omega.
I suspect, actually, that
because of that algebraic sign
error I made, the
minus sign down here,
actually I think that this
comes out with a minus sign.
But I won't guarantee that
on the spot right now--
you can simply
verify that, but I
suspect that there should
be a minus sign there.
OK, well this, then,
represents the phase shift
that would be encountered
by a sinusoidal input going
through the linear
shift invariant system.
This would represent the
square of the magnitude
change of a sinusoidal input.
And if we were to sketch
this, then what we see
is that at omega equal to
0, cosine omega of course
at omega equal to 0 is 1.
So this is 1 over 1 plus a
squared minus 2 a, or 1 over 1
minus a quantity squared.
We're assuming that
a is between 0 and 1,
and so we're indicated
that by this value.
When omega is equal
to pi, cosine omega
is equal to minus 1.
This, then, comes out to be 1
over 1 plus a quantity squared,
which for a between 0 and
1 is less than this value.
So the frequency response, then,
between minus pi and plus pi,
would have the shape
that I've indicated here.
Now, what happens if we
continue on in frequency-- omega
can, of course, run from pi
to 2 pi, and on past that.
You can verify in a
very straightforward way
from this expression
that, from pi to 2 pi,
the frequency response
will look exactly like it
did from minus pi to pi.
It will, then, look like that.
And for minus pi
to minus 2 pi, it
will look exactly as it
did from pi down to 0.
So it will look like this.
And in fact, it's
straightforward to verify
for both the magnitude and
the phase that both of those
are periodic in omega,
with a period of 2 pi.
So this is one period,
say, from minus pi to pi,
and then another period
would start from pi to 3 pi.
And it would continue
on like that.
So, in fact, if we
were to sketch this out
over a wider range of
omega, we would see
this periodically repeating.
For this example, that's
straightforward to verify.
So there are, then, two
properties of the frequency
response which I would like
to call your attention to
in preparation for our
discussion next time.
One of them is the
fact, very important
to keep in mind, that the
frequency response, as we're
talking about it, is a function
of a continuous variable,
omega.
Omega, I hadn't stressed
this point previously,
but omega is a variable
that changes continuously
over whatever range
we're talking about,
as opposed to sequences which
are functions, obviously,
of a discrete variable.
Here we're talking
about a function
of a continuous variable, omega.
As we saw, for our example,
the frequency response
is a periodic function of omega.
And the period is equal to 2 pi.
Now, the reason that it's a
periodic function of omega
is, in fact, somewhat obvious.
Suppose that we take a complex
exponential, e to the j omega
n, and inquire as to how
the complex exponential
itself behaves if we change
omega over an interval of more
than 2 pi.
Suppose that we replace omega
by omega plus 2 pi times k,
and now if we decompose
this into a product,
we have e to the j omega
n, times e to the j
2 pi k times n.
This is an integer
multiple-- this exponent
is an integer multiple of 2 pi.
And so this is simply
equal to unity.
Now what that says, is that
a complex exponential--
once we've varied omega
over an interval of 2 pi,
and we go past that,
there are no more
no new complex
exponentials to see.
We'll see the same ones over
and over and over again.
And consequently,
the system response
has to be periodic in
omega with period 2 pi,
because we're putting in,
essentially, the same inputs
over and over and over again.
This is a point that I'll be
mentioning from time to time,
and it's, in fact, somewhat
important to keep in mind.
Also, it's discussed in some
detail again in the text.
So these, then,
are some properties
of the frequency response.
There is a generalization of
the frequency response, which
is, in fact, very important
for describing both signals
and systems.
The generalization is what
we'll refer to as the Fourier
transform, which plays
the identical role
in the discrete time case
that the Fourier transform did
in the continuous time case.
And so in the next
lecture, we'll
be going on to a
discussion of the Fourier
transform taking off
from the set of ideas
that we've developed here, with
regard to frequency response.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]